yoyoyo
hello
i think we're live
i can never tell
with youtube
hello
what up flanders puff puff
silly bee
yoda
diablo
mission control alpha
terrinator
miro lone wolf
what up guys
we live
welcome welcome welcome
we are going to see how far we can get
with this today
we might
we might be able to finish
the completionist playthrough maybe
potentially
what up caleb yo
yo yo yo
we're gonna see there's still a lot
to do
but i think there's a lot of it we can
do very quickly
because at this point we've beaten
melania so if we're if we're beating
millennia
we're pretty good like we're good
it's a [ __ ] and thumbnail it is really
cool go check out the artist in the
description
if you're curious it is actually really
really cool
[Music]
hello hello
let's get it i think the first thing i
want to do today is just go beat malaka
i think that's a good start
beat malacath and then
probably
we'll wait on gideon
we'll wait on gideon
so
yeah
we'll beat malketh and then we'll go do
all the little little bosses all over
the place because i'm pretty sure we've
done every single
quest line that we can do
oh we still need to uh
get grank his uh death his death root as
well
you guys are gonna have to help help me
on where the hell this death root is
because i have no idea is he attacking
me right now no
hello
yeah he's just mad so we got to get more
three bosses for gideon yeah we're gonna
do all the little bosses everywhere
after we beat malacath that's my plan we
already beat this i beat this guy off
stream um for the video
that i made a couple days ago
so
he's
dead gideon's the hardest in the game
yes we did celin's questline we ended up
killing uh
jiren
and now she is a
is she still there yes i think she's
just a
weird-looking ball creature
right here yep there she is
good esther how are you
oh god
she can still teach us though
i love how she just doesn't say anything
do we know if ranala is the one that did
that to her it has to be right
probably
smasher pass in her current form
i'm sure i'd know what you all say let's
go beat malcot though cause we beat
dragonlord
um we can come back here after we
release dust and death though right
yeah yeah yeah yeah we can
um
yeah
let's go fight malacath
this might take us a minute too
mal kept this
tough but if we can beat melania
we can kind of do anything
i guess i'll fight this guy
is that her punishment
i'm not sure i don't know the lore of
why she's like
that's it dude
i hate fighting these guys
i feel like i'm doing no damage
my dodges are nice today
looking good
never mind
okay
i'm just gonna spam our fireballs good
why is there a draconic tree sentinel
here does anybody know
bro
oh god
almost died
i thought i could kill him there oh god
could have him
here as i say that
ah
i'm going back down here
guys you're so annoying to fight i don't
know about how everybody feels about
them but i'm just like
[Music]
who's your favorite boss
uh radon 100 radon everything about
radon i like
hold on i need to fix the chat
too low for me
you there we go
who would you date an elden ring why do
we have this conversation every day
just every day
yo what up cole yeah we just started bro
how we doing
yeah we're not changing our uh our build
at all
this is the build
defend death and death
remember they were defenders of the
urgery
through
thou
who approacheth
destined death
a medal i will not have it stolen
trying to relearn the move set here
decent damage
ow
that hurt
[Music]
oh my god that goes way back
that back step will get you if you're
not careful
right here
that one right there that'll that'll cut
you up
didn't think he had the range bro
oh
camera
camera
back step
nice
oh come on bro
got me there
hold up i don't wanna use this
let's use it
all right cool we're just gonna spam
that's fine
[Music]
boy spamming
wow
first try
phase one
very nice
the first one is fun seen them so often
you mean all the tree sentinels yeah
why do we want to chew everything
i can't change my build at all lone wolf
remember a video where
people summon different bosses to kill
melania and malketh
malik is the only one that beat melania
i could see that considering she like
just he destroys your health bar
thank you lance appreciate it man
what up snail
oh yeah your wisdom teeth i forgot bro
gotta get got to get uh those hot wings
out again
more wings
all right let's see how we do
this is tough
i'm here brother
good start
this fight is really cool
away from that
i didn't do that
didn't do the getting away part
wow
that's that's bad
oh my god okay we're alive somehow
[Music]
that's just unfair
no i should have healed there
dodges are on point today though
like that that was pretty good for a
first try
malchet's just an oversized dog just let
him sit so if i go out there and say sit
then i'll win
maybe dude
i never get mad when malcolm x
yeah i think melania is unfair in a lot
of ways but i don't think malacath is
unfair
blithe's brother he wants to avenge his
little brother
i mean
technically they could be brothers
because they're both shadows of the
greater will
bit
he didn't sit
he's not trained
okay how far does this go
as far as it wants
apparently
i just want these
blind dodge
not good not good not good
you [ __ ]
raleigh should have healed earlier we'll
take it now though
not a good start
little
that he's just spamming all of his be
steel [ __ ]
i don't know how that hit me that's fine
went for a jump attack like a dummy this
is really bad
nice
he's reaching bro
getting better as we go
dodges are on point again
very nice
okay i shouldn't i shouldn't have spoke
all right
phase two
can i get this off
yep
that's not that bad
we'll take it
i need to get behind him there
that's tough though
perfect
[Music]
i'll take it
that's a later dodge
that's a late notch
got it
didn't think i got it there but we did
not what i thought he was gonna do this
is not good
it's gonna be
close take a little hit there that's all
right that's all right
get one heal
it's gonna be close
might have been risky
i think we got him
there it is
few tries
no i wanted to dab
i want to dab on them haters
ratagon
might be really hard with this build by
the way i saw i saw that pascal i agree
didn't get the alternative dialogue we
all know what the alternative dialogue
is
w
oh yeah i played with the blasphemous
claw it's pretty cool
dude rick looks so [ __ ] cool
the dab was how you made him sit
gotcha
gotcha now we got to do all the little
the little boss fights between us
shrouded
by death's dark
fate but the flames
will also burn the impenetrable thorns
damn
it is then
you'll be elden lord yet
any tips into new game plus for the
other endings no i mean
do the research on how to do them but
that's all
our point for this is to have all of our
options at the end
rick's just taking a nap
i want death rune as a great rune to use
what do you think it would do if you
could
oh yeah we're doing the rick video it's
gonna be really good i'm excited
i'm very excited to show you guys the
rick video
it's gonna be really good
coming along
might be a few days but you'll see it
all right what are we leveling here a
little bit of strength a little bit of
dex doesn't even matter
we're pretty much done leveling
let's do
i mean health isn't really gonna help us
that much
it's two levels let's just do that
yes this is a soldier of god
his name is rick playthrough
bored
why does my voice like feel deeper today
what's going on
you level decks yes it scales with the
sword
rick is smarter than you all will know
oh and we need to get all the stuff for
the dung eater so maybe we do you guys
want to do that first
let's find out where all the death roots
are
and then we can find out where all of
the things for him are as well
for the dung for the dung eta
you're gonna decimate
yes i think we're gonna decimate the
mini bosses let me pull up my uh
my list actually did not have it ready
pro streamer by the way
do you know which death root you already
have probably not
no
i don't um
let's do
google cheats
bye
so we just beat malacath
which is here and we beat place of
dewsacks poggers
got rattagon here
tibia mariners
and some catacombs
okay
we'll see we'll see
so mountaintop there's a misbegotten
crusader in the mountaintops of the
giants what
this is going to be interesting to go
through all of these bosses because i i
doubt i've beaten every boss in the game
before
yep i checked off placidus x we beat
moog
uh
why does this say here
is moog here
well we can't kill patches because he
was a part of a quest line
i guess we could kill him now
you get one from loretta
for real
i know where this death bird is
we could do that
to start i kind of want to start in a
certain area let's start in mount glimer
because it's such a concentrated area
that we could just like get it done
let's go to mount glimer and start there
let's do that first and we'll we'll pick
it up we'll pick it up
that's over here
i i still have to beat that uh falling
star beast
which should be
merchants there
campsite
i think that puts me up in the crater
yeah
you have to beat mogan two places yeah
we fought him way underground and uh at
mogwin's palace so we got him done
let's beat this guy
can you remove my chat band from another
account
so can someone banned him for literally
saying that he's been banned before and
now he's banned evading
why would you tell me that dumbass
the thumbnail arts in the description
dude i forgot how to fight these things
holy [ __ ]
all right buddy
holy
nice
thank you metal
very nice
yes we beat melania
yesterday
dude that's so hard to dodge
you're not going to give me a second to
move or either are you
yeah if you were banned on another
account why would you tell me you're
banned
i think we're just very dumb
you probably got me in for a reason
buddy
oh what his leg hit me
there we go i'm gonna try this this time
yeah it does way more damage and i get
bold
come on yes
first try we are op for all these guys
now aren't we
you should have said sorry i mean that
would have helped instead of just
saying hey i'm banned unban me on a
different account
what a dude what a goober dude
did you watch the most recent xylostorm
i watched a little bit of it because i
saw you uh in chat telling me to watch
it
so i watched like five minutes of it
before stream
look cool
okay i'm gonna release remind me to
check things off after we beat bosses
please because i have a really bad
tendency to just like
forget and then we come back to this and
forget who we've beaten
uh have to clear merchants
virgins
where's the tibia mariner
brainer ernier
up in her
red wolf of the champion
oh oh we beat reichard i don't know why
i didn't check that off god devouring
serpent is the same thing so i'll check
that off
ancient dragon
loretta knight of the halo tree let me
check that off
where red a night of the halogen tree we
beat melania
we had we could go and be a still no
let's stay here we're going to stay here
okay where's margaret because we beat
maggie but where's
demi human queen margaret
is by the erd tree
gazing hill
isn't that here
around altus plateau
two virgins at the same time i think i
know where that is so let's just go
there
that's like uh hidden in this area right
yeah
forget how to go there though
let's go prison town
yes we beat the god skin noble in
volcano manor
should be near hermit village okay
margaret the demi human queen is in a
cave in glimmer okay okay
i'll look out for that as well so
we have to get way down there actually
so
i can go this way
yeah do you have to get kidnapped i
don't think so
what ending are you gonna do uh whatever
chat wants when we get there
so if everyone wants flame a frenzy then
i won't i won't get rid of the flame of
frenzy um but if they want to do a
different ending
we'll vote on it see what people
want most enjoyable boss
radon all the way around radon is
absolutely incredible
i think he's the
best boss in all of from software
you do you can't reach it otherwise
i don't know bro i think they're down
here
we gonna find out
if not we'll get a
abducted
i think there's a magma worm over here
right
we already beat it
oh
is it a boss nope
not a boss
that's what we wanted
really cool that there's lava directly
in my back
raleigh should be looking for sacred
tears as well
just don't remember where all of them
are
oh no
bro i hate fighting these things so much
how do i hit you
there we go
radon's the main character
i think that's my most successful video
i could probably make an updated video
on radon
but probably not necessary
because i made that video like two
months ago it's kind of a long time
no magma worm down there well sir
i don't know if that was
right was it the other door
trying to do the back step
your theory about ronnie's two fingers
in that video at the end of it is why
i'm telling you to watch it oh really
i'll have to give it a watch
can i watch it on stream is that allowed
can i do that
i don't know what i can and can't do on
youtube sometimes man
jesus walks on water
rick walks on lava
okay this isn't doesn't seem like the
way
these walls fake
do that
please i mean we can
alright if i get in trouble i'm blaming
you guys okay
hold on
because i don't think it's very long
what's up with the comments not showing
up
on what what do you mean
permission granted
wow there's a lot of people here thank
you
see i was watching it earlier i got four
minutes in
rick won't let you get in trouble okay
let me restart all right what's going on
guys this very well can i just say
zio storm
has the best voice
ever well maybe the last i just like his
voice discoveries videos because now
that the game has been out for a while a
lot of the things that can appeal to the
mass of the player base you know
comments surface level gameplay
discoveries have already been found and
you know my goal with these videos is to
show you something that you probably
didn't know and so as time goes on those
i want to know things that i didn't know
before more and more obscure but that
doesn't mean i don't have some good
stuff for you today so do me a favor and
hit that subscribe button if i show you
something that you didn't know subscribe
the way let's get into it first up on
the list today i'm subscribing to
surface level gameplay discoveries that
a lot of you may have known about but i
personally didn't and now i kind of feel
like an idiot because at the time of
recording this a new update had just
come out for eldon ring that fixes the
issue that we're about to talk about
because did you know that the map around
the divine tower of lyernia in jarburg
is actually wrong or at least was wrong
until about a few hours ago because it
depicted oh yeah
according to the map prior to the update
the little dirt road past the left side
of the study hall stretches all the way
down to jarburg however as you can
clearly see there is no such road here
now i gotta be honest with you guys
during my first playthrough i saw this
road on the map and i spit bro did you
just tell me to shut up
i will go back to what we were doing and
you can go watch this video on your own
time but you guys wanted me to watch it
don't tell me to shut up spent like 50
minutes trying to find it no i really
didn't think the map was just wrong and
i thought i was just being stupid and
didn't see it but sure enough that road
just did not exist but thankfully with
this new update now when you check the
map it is updated accordingly and
properly shows the gap between the
cliffs there up next did you know that
the black knife assassins can trace
their origin to greek mythology the
black knife assassins were the
mysterious party who killed godwin the
golden on the night of the black knives
we don't have an exact number of how
many assassins there were however we do
know of two that are uniquely named
those i'm just gonna ban you i don't
like you guy just says yes
bye
[ __ ] you
[ __ ]
with alecto being the ring leader of the
group but when you start if i don't like
you i ban you simple as a little bit
interesting because it takes you to a
group of creatures in greek mythology
known as the furies the furies were
female deities of vengeance who would
hear the complaints of mortals and work
to take revenge for them in the cover of
night but things start to get really
interesting when we consider the lore of
the black knife assassins black knife
assassins are also described as
all-female newman and roger tells us
that they're scions of the eternal city
like imagine telling the streamer to
shut up people but now makes a lot more
sense don't watch the stream that you
[ __ ] idiot you may notice that a lot
of the architecture is very reminiscent
of ancient greek the furies according to
myth are described as hailing from
beneath the ground the eternal cities
are beneath the ground in the home of a
people called the knox quite a little
bit of trivia about this the furies are
said to be children of a people called
the knicks so it's really cool to see a
little bit of inspiration there of which
there is a lot more to dig into when it
comes to elden ring patches there's been
a lot if you're toxic to me i'm
toxically released in the patch notes
and so a lot of that doesn't make our
community toxic that would have
otherwise been obviously known if they
had been included in the patch notes but
one of these things that flew under the
radar that would have otherwise been
obvious is actually a major change made
to morgoth's cutscene before patch 1.04
bro do you guys remember when i said
this we fought morgot
and i totally remember pointing this out
to you guys where i was like i swear
when i first played the game it makes
fire here is the casing on his blade it
breaks off in sort of this flaming tinge
and clouds of smoke rise from its search
probably a larger thing raises several
questions why is this something they
would even bother changing and what are
the implications of flame being
something associated with morgue no i
haven't maybe a practical
morgot doesn't actually use any fire
attacks and this is zio storm so perhaps
this change was made not to lead people
in the wrong direction and get them to
expect some fire when there isn't going
to be any but we also have some
reasoning within yeah
it's no secret that morgot is wholly
devoted to the golden order so much so
that he forsakes his almond blood
sealing it away with the power of the
blood flame however the power of flame
is something seen as heretical to the
golden order which explains why he only
uses it as a last-ditch effort in the
second phase of the fight right so
perhaps this change does make a little
bit more sense on the lure side i guess
maybe they just wanted to subvert the
player's expectation and let the flame
be a surprise in that second phase think
that let me know what you think down
below more on it this next discovery
comes from crunchy who makes some
absolutely fantastic lore videos
definitely check his channel out but he
was perusing the text files of the game
and came across something very
interesting which appears to be a cut
event with muriel at the church of vows
it looks to be the dialogue of an event
where he would give us a unique sword
but let me read this to you real quick
are you taking the sword with you oh
fear not i don't wish to chide you
clearly you are no conniving thief the
sword is telling us something no doubt
rather than collect dust in the shadows
underground it yearns to be wielded by
your rightful hand ah now i recall as
priest of the church of vows i undo the
sword seal and bequeath it unto you may
you hold it high and proud cool this is
really interesting because i think i
might know which sword this could be and
i think that if i'm right it might also
explain why this part was cut a big
mystery in the game is how we acquire
the golden order greatsword which is the
sword of ratagon after he became joined
with queen america we get this sword in
a random cave in the consecrated snow
fields after a boss fight with a
misbegotten and it feels extremely old
yeah given muriel's connection around
it would make a lot more sense if we got
this sword from him and radagon is known
for having his own unique seal which we
know is barring us from entering the erd
tree so if muriel was able to break
ratagan's seal i can see how that would
be a major plot hole so maybe that's why
it was cut but there may be more to find
within the game files regarding this cut
event but let me know your thoughts down
below this next one is kind of weird
because it's more of a discovery of a
question rather than an answer because
have you ever stopped and looked around
at the environmental storytelling of the
cathedral of menace
this is my third alter the place where
ronnie's two fingers is ultimately slain
the cathedral is completely destroyed
with the wreckage lining up with the
hole that we find the two fingers in
almost giving the impression that the
two fingers crash landed here totally
agree obviously really weird however
there's a theory with this that i think
is super interesting and i wanted to
tell you all about now this may not be
true but a lot of people on reddit were
talking about it and we're gonna run
with it for a second oh ready theory
that when ronnie cast aside her flesh
she also sealed away her great rune on
the moon since there's some lines on the
moon that kind of looked like a rune and
she sealed that room there her two
fingers were also sealed away however
after defeating radon the stars are set
back in motion and ronnie is able to
yeah reddit stole it from me
here's the difference i don't care so
the theory goes that the reason we find
her two fingers deep underground in the
cathedral up above is
destroyed pixels perhaps the two fingers
quite literally came down with the stars
crash landing into the earth and
scattering the starlight shards around
everywhere which we seemingly have no
explanation for so i'm not too sure
about that one but it is a really fun
way at potentially explaining away some
of the questions we've been having i
think that makes the most logical sense
i really do know your thoughts on that
up next did you know that much of the
game's visual inspiration comes from old
paintings by bexinsky he was a polish
painter known for his baroque or gothic
style which i'm sure you'll recognize
even if you've never seen some of his
paintings because much of dark souls
also draws its inspiration from his
style but there are some i'm a reaction
youtuber now this is what we do
seems to take very direct inspiration
from this one one aspect of the games
that i never these paintings are
skeletons on the thrones but after
seeing this painting it is unmistakable
and the deathride birds can credit their
inspiration
his style of painting definitely
inspired a lot of the more eldritch
stuff we see in video games today and
other media it's got that very twisted
and uneasy atmosphere to it while also
creating a sense of solace or attraction
to the weirdness of it which i can
appreciate very much and definitely sets
the mood for these games something i've
been thinking about a lot lately is the
botany of elden ring and so something
that intrigued me quite a bit is that
the ghost we find around the world of
the little mushrooms also have little
phantom mushrooms coming out of the
ground around them and so it got me
thinking about what are the significance
of the mushrooms we find around elden
ring i know the red mushrooms seem to be
in close link with an outer god of rot
however i was thinking about a popular
theory that's going around that the
archery is some sort of parasitic
organism and this is based on the item
description of the root resin which
insinuates that the erd tree took over a
once great tree whose roots yeah yeah
yeah i was about to say homes yet we
never see the actual tree well like the
golden order is taken over the tree that
came before it but notice that the er
tree doesn't even really look like a
tree obviously it is because it has
branches and leaves but it looks much
closer to a mushroom so let me show you
a kind of really connection we know the
erd tree emerged after a meteorite
containing the elden beast arrived in
the lands between the great tree was
likely destroyed in this process and
golden meteorites infected its roots the
gold that we see is said to be the amber
of starlight or the erd tree but we have
noticed that about those dungeons it's
always always in this type of area
studies have found that certain fungal
spores can survive the vacuum and
radiation of space travel leading to
some very off-the-wall hypothesis that
certain mushrooms may have arrived long
ago on asteroids and we do know that the
erd tree is growing from the roots of
the great tree which has a purpose in
decaying the dead so is the herd tree
some kind of weird i need to look at the
tree more but that's just i think it
looks like a tree of the day for the
final one i don't think it looks like a
mushroom but maybe feedback on i don't
know that much about mushrooms before
this connection goes is in the formless
oedon rune from bloodborne now yes i
know bloodborne is a completely
different game the lore is not connected
whatsoever and from software
continuously likely to reference their
past work made reuse themes just like
with the centipedes throughout all their
games however this one really stuck out
to me and i wanted to hear y'all's
thoughts about it in eldon ring we know
moog has a strong connection to an outer
god called the formless mother and
through the broccoli that elder god he's
able to channel the powers of blood and
in bloodborne oh adot a great one who is
known as formless and only in voice has
an extremely strong connection with the
worship and use of blood and i just
couldn't help but see the little golden
rooms that we see in there look like it
looks like a smiley face
so i'm not gonna run with that too much
because it is bloodborne and ultimately
a different game however it is a pretty
cool little piece of did you know trivia
but guys that's going to pretty much do
it for the video yeah we need to get the
69 420 subs that's the last one of these
videos however as time goes on the last
one in this game are getting more and
more obscure and diving into the
speculation territory which i love and
will continue to talk about yeah you're
gonna get a lot of [ __ ] from speculating
though trust me
but the problem is there's a very
limited amount you're gonna get a lot of
[ __ ] for speculating in any way do me a
favor and leave a like and hit that
subscribe button i'm starting to say
screw it i don't care
good video
but check out zion storm guys he is i
like his videos a lot i've been
subscribed for a while but go check him
out he is dope i love his voice
big fan of the voice
good video good video
all right let's get it let's get it
though what are we doing again we're
trying to find
we're trying to find some virgins
depends on how much sense the theories
make
man i can't wait to show you guys my
next video man
i guess you guys already know but
to everybody else who isn't in these
streams
and that we're gonna make this rick
video all of it's [ __ ]
i'm just so curious how people are gonna
react
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah if you clarify at the
beginning that it's your personal theory
then people are a little bit kinder with
it
but people get mad when you don't
why don't they make the story clear
is this your first from software game
is is this your first one
it sounds like it
because uh
yeah
you're uh
not gonna get that man
you absolutely can conan go for it dude
oh yeah tan it's eating reichardt that's
right
um
okay i guess i do have to go get
captured let me spin my rooney boys
oh i could also put on a branch if i
have one i don't really care about runes
anymore i'm not worried about leveling
too much
not worried about leveling at all oh and
we're good okay
let's go get captured this is going to
be the easiest way to get there
um
so i think if i go
yeah yeah schoolhouse schoolhouse
will you kill tanith nam i'm not gonna
mess with tanith
it's not a boss fight
who is rick
i
am rick
dab
where did we get this sword guys i don't
remember
you fighting godfrey today we might be
able to finish today depending on how
fast we can find all these bosses
so i'm gonna need your guys's help
we're gonna focus on one boss at a time
and see how we get down to it
dude a tattoo of a great room is
actually a really good idea
cypher
that's a really good idea
i'd consider that
pollinator and coal cipher let's go
yeah didn't i buy it from a merchant i
think
yeah south limb grave
all right let's get capped oh wait i
needed to hurt me a bit
hurt me first i have so much health
ow
now
hurt me a little bit more mommy
a little bit more
okay that's definitely enough
i might die before we get captured now
dude i am mad
dang it
how do i struggle with getting captured
i should just let it capture me like two
or three times and we're good i don't
know why i made that more complicated
than it needed to be
i didn't expect the uh
the blood loss there
oof
strongest weapon lore wise i have no
idea
i think that's subjective
hey
i chat
hey
you have a full elden ring tattooed on
your chest
threw for it didn't happen
hey
dude i want to play the new harry potter
game really bad
we might have to dive into that because
that would be fun dude that game looks
good
uh patches tells you about this area or
this way to get to volcano manor
actually pat just tells you
that's true metal
that's true
that barely hurts me [ __ ]
if you guys don't want to get hurt just
stand right in front of it
i'm trying to get hit there we go
that kill me now oh yeah
oh yeah
you need to watch the movies to play the
game
are you kidding me with this health
yes thank you
you haven't seen harry potter my guy
i mean you'd probably be really confused
but yeah
patches is an outer god
it could be
could be
you like patches or hate him
i
hate i i don't
he's a he's a literal troll
so
he's all right he's he's funny
me
oops
yeah i think i go down in this cave
right
what up middle
how can anyone hate patches i mean he
destroyed like he he trolls you that's
probably the biggest reason
bro
flying enemies in this game
tough
the hit
magic users right now are like no
they're not i didn't have an issue at
all
i wonder why
it's a love-hate relationship with
patches
considering patches was a spider in a
bloodborne
literal spider
pretty funny
such an interesting area
you
are dead
this is the xyle hander
caught you live twice hooray for my
schedule working what up justin how are
you
i use magic
hey hey
if you like using magic i hope you have
a great time with it
i don't
but
i hope you do
smithing four huh kind of kind of ink
all right so you guys said there's two
virgins back here
oh [ __ ]
hello
a lot of cave moss all right
a battle mage yeah i bet it is really
fun i just really like uh
swords
why is there no cars in this game
uh
i don't know
great question
ow
of course when i don't want to get
captured i get captured huh
dude i
i don't want to talk about it
i don't want to talk about it
please don't grab me again thank you
fringe
wow
okay then
let me swing one time thank you okay
done
uh done
where does this take me now oh it
doesn't take me anywhere
wait
cool
you can spam the buttons like a monkey
to escape more quickly i
did hear about that
i knew it wouldn't kill me so i didn't
really care eldon ring torrent ferrari
car mod
great idea
this is a great view
what
oh it pokes you out here
interesting
up okay nobody reminded me
i had to remind myself which is scary
because i'm not good at that
okay
virgins
dead all right let's go see what's over
here
over in that water is a tibia murderer
over here
let's go check it out
i see purple flowers
the windham ruins
see a dead people
did we already kill it and we just
didn't know
did i already kill him
i may i very well may have i just don't
even know
what it would have been in that spot
a bunch of dead people
bunch of dead mofo
i killed him already
i bet
and look around
oh yeah see we've been we've been here
let's see what this is
yeah we definitely killed him
already
hey yo what's going on in here
fringe
i haven't seen those scary skelly guys
we'll get one
here we can get two
forgot how y'all work
okay
that was easy i thought this would be a
boss
cringe
okay
so we got the tibia
tibia uh mount glimmier
[Music]
mariner
okay
where is uh someone said told me where
margaret is
where's that
oh
perfumer didn't we kill this this flower
i swear we did
i might be thinking of a different
flower though
um i don't see this is why we need to we
really need to get on this so we killed
the godskin noble
as well
soldier of godric allure video it's it's
it's cooking
it's cooking
what flour
[Music]
i just i could just pull up the
minecraft wiki
as well
minecraft did i say minecraft wiki eldon
ring wiki
no we could probably learn from
minecraft too
see i hated godskin noble as well and i
don't find it that hard anymore did i go
in this cave yet
it looks like i did
oh i know what we can do
i'm just now it's just on my brain
so
yeah it's just on my brain on my mind
i have to go down
yeah yeah
because i've been asking you to play
minecraft with me for the past three
days you know like you know how hard it
is to be a gaming content creator
and you have friends
who love to play games when they're done
with work but your work is playing games
all day so then when they get done with
work they ask you to play more games and
you're just like
damn i'm i'm all gamed out bro
uh battlefield he drops talisman at that
one
[Music]
the grace called the battlefield
i don't know what you're talking about
sorry
oh yeah i went to the wrong spot
we go here
i get it you hate me that's that's not
that's not what i said
i just i wish you guys live near here so
we could like go do things that aren't
playing games because i'm so gamed out
at the end of the day like when i'm not
streaming guys i'm still playing elden
ring i'm recording it
i'm actually going through the game
again
to get 4k recording because i'm a [ __ ]
and love high quality videos
and i'm getting all these cinematic
shots with a with the cinematic camera
mod
and stuff see that's where i want to go
yeah in there yep yep
i'm constantly doing [ __ ] bro constantly
[Music]
and they're like jake you won't play
minecraft i'm like oh
yes i do i'm so gamed out
he really doesn't i love you
i do
i do
flying buying a plane ticket see you
tomorrow okay
you need a vacation no i [ __ ] love it
i love it dude it's great
i'm just talking about playing more
games
uh after i've been gaming all day
i love it man
awesome
all right cool
so i think we go down here we go through
this dungeon we gotta fight two crucible
knights
at the same time
godric the minecrafted
yes we beat melania yesterday
took us three hours three and a half
hours somewhere around there
i opened what's the point i'm not
opening that we might need that even
though i can buy more
oh god
this is a fat hole bro
hey yo what up cup
i got bad vibes
there it is
don't be fast all right
so on the way up
that's so cringe and i hate it
um
spooky
whew
gotcha released his mixtapes here huh
i think you're right
this is where rick recorded those huh
you don't need that anymore
[ __ ] i don't know where it is
okay
hey
i just lost that huge
ginormous value
oh now you come down lower huh
look at me go i'm the best
so smart
yeah i've tried killing the chariots
it's whatever i it's easy to run past
them as well when you know what you're
doing
rick is a better rapper than tupac i
think that goes without saying
of course
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah i know what you can do i
just don't wanna
all right who remembers this twitch
stream of me doing this for four hours
nice okay so they're attacking at the
same time pretty much
you you seem aggro no you seem aggro now
i think i was level like [ __ ]
30 when i was here
somehow
so much anger was had in this fight
now
input
looks like i healed
and we got a fight
i like how one of them has a name and
the other one is just no name
it's like nobody cares
look at that
look how far we've come since we started
yeah that was a bit faster to swing than
you usually
do what
all right whatever i don't care
all right whatever
i think i care
oh
try look how far we've come
we were here for
four hours three months ago
first try look at us
you could say we're the best all right
let's mark it
mark it off
so that is altus plateau or is it real
capital yep row capital boom boom look
at us go we're the best
all right
we are pretty good at this game
let's go so we did that
let's look at our list let's look at our
list you know
okay
balbarian hunter okay where's a
balbarian hunter in the royal capital oh
okay well now i'm getting distracted and
we're going caleb
because i know where a balbarian hunter
is over here that we have not beaten
let's go over here
there's a sword in there that's great
i don't care i'm not going to use it i
have everything i need for my build so
not not using it
past time nightfall
yay dab
i'm still here so i need to get up
sit
and he's gone
perfect
okay okay so i think i know where it
will be
in the capital
owned
checklist is in the description
excuse me
i i'll take it you know it is what it is
all right lit
ella fighting against people that knock
you down on into a grab and then
they immediately attack you before you
can even get up
yeah it's it's a dark wraith
it actually is
let's try that again
kill two crucible knights can't kill
that guy first try
this is a scary fight it's really cool
though
do this again
hey i did the same attack forehead oh
god
well
that's not good
i'm gonna die right away yep cause you
do that one attack
[Music]
dude this guy's so hard to fight
what do i do
i don't know what to do there
i have no idea what to do when he's
doing that i think i just have to dodge
like perfectly because he's going to get
the sword
over where you are no matter what
and also i killed elmer
are these guys different
like different people
we'll get it we'll get it
this is weird
just the timing's really awkward with
him
okay
see that time he didn't do that
and he just holds it
dude this is [ __ ] really hard holy
crap
yeah i thought they were the same person
too at least they look exactly the same
this is harder than radon
[ __ ] hell
oh we did kill melania that is true so
he's mad
yep
yep
that's that's true
rip our runes
i'm simping you
now what
bro
hey thanks for the five man
i'm sipping you now
i don't think that's how that goes but i
appreciate it thank you
thank you man
holy [ __ ]
elmer is the strongest in the lance
thank you thank you
he wants to see your toes
yes
come on
i thought it'd make him stagger actually
didn't get it
either okay so sometimes he goes really
fast and sometimes he goes really really
slow
that's that's what's weird about this
fight
he doesn't let you heal
wow
what is happening
this guy's straight up super hard
have you tried winning
no
it's so tough
leave behind him
man just turns on me
i mean that'll work much damage 144
[Music]
it does more damage for me to do this
i die in two hits
how is this possible
i just die so [ __ ] fast to him
also the setup to get the fight on is
kind of annoying
getting bullshitted
i don't know if this is [ __ ] i think
this is really hard
can i use them i can't use a mimic here
oh i'm dead
what dude
how many different attacks do you have
dog all right
he has so many different speeds and
variations how do you even do this
i mean we've beaten one before but this
one is insane
these combos are just
unbelievable
and he does all of my health
in like two hits
i have like 40 some health
you can tell what he's doing
bro this is i'm gonna keep saying the
same thing over and over again i guess
this is insane
i don't have any ranged weapons
i mean i want to do it how rick would do
it but this is insane
i think he's just really hard
knew that stagger you you
should have healed
that's just my fault [ __ ]
i'm not summoning people stop you guys
are so annoying
not summoning i'm not changing what i'm
doing i want to beat him like how rick
would beat him just like we did with
melania
that was greedy that was my fault
okay
dude
i was doing so good i was getting the
dodges down and but you just die
you can't use a mimic here
my dodges were nuts there though
hell
this seems unbalanced
a bit
no idea where that's
no
that's my fault
[ __ ]
this is justin caleb
this seems insanely unbalanced for this
area
guys stop backseating i i'm gonna say
this one time today stop backseating
stop
i'm gonna do it the way i want
you guys are really prone to backseating
hardcore
it it doesn't help
i'll get it
let's let it happen
probably need to metal
damn it
no offense
i was surprised he only swung once there
damn it
please stop
canal
forgot
so
there you go you foreheads
just let it happen
friggin backseaters dude
just let me get good it'll happen
eventually
took three hours with melania but that
one took like 10 minutes maybe a little
less
donkey
ultra instinct unlocked i i told you let
me pin your message though
jake is doing his play through the way
he wants to thank you
and
there we go hopefully uh
that'll help
the streamers got no maidens okay
i know you guys aren't ever trying to
backseat i don't even think you guys
realize that you do
but
yeah it doesn't help
just meme along
snow it's just annoying
all right
i think we can time out people who just
continue to do it with uh
the pinned message and we're just now
talking about it and they're still doing
it that's
quite crazy
okay
um
that was here
and that is
right here
i've never heard of battle mage huge
queen rotten knight cemetery shade
archery avatar and caleb we can go do
that did we beat the dragon here as well
isn't that close to here
it's over here
favorite npc
um
hmm
i
i keep thinking millicent
i like millicent
it's in an abergaill
have fun cole
yeah you can tell me to not die
but uh yeah
you asked for help though where did i
ask for help
where did i ask for you to like give me
your tip on how to beat it
looks like i did beat the dragon because
i don't see it
okay dragon dead
dragon dead
that is
the kane ex-i is that the dragon
elder dragon grail
no it's this
gotta be the dragon
for flying dragon grail oh that's the
elder dragon that's not even a boss is
it
no i'm not counting those
why are these on here
let's see
oh we can go beat the knights cavalry
it's ike zykesies
decaying zyke sees okay
thank you
i would say the elder dragon doesn't
count right
the one that lays on the ground it's
it's the giant giant giant dragon
the evergles the other way okay it's
because i'm not doing anything right now
where is an abergail i should be able to
see it on the map right here
looks like an everglade to me
ever jail sorry
people got mad at me when i kept calling
it evergills
oh wait
i think that's that's not it
that's like uh an elevator or whatever
no i'm not sponsored by opera i just
like it
i think that's an elevator no that's to
the right it's just up here okay
yeah i just print out that's just what
it [ __ ] says in my head but
i made a video where i talked about some
evergales ever jails and
i would say the most comments i received
were just like you're pronouncing it
wrong
it's ever jail
i was like okay
okay
would you rather the power of the dark
soul or the elden ring
oh
i don't know that's a tough question pbh
how do i get over there what am i doing
right now
hey that hurt wow that hurt
i think i just went the wrong way
i got this
it's by the fort that you guys were
saying
go this way
that was some kind of tyrannosaurus
dog
what's up joseph
what's a dark soul i feel bad for you
guys
can't believe some of you haven't played
dark souls man
[Music]
not gonna worry about that
we got work to do
there it is
yes we defeated
melania yesterday
all right who we got here
wow very powerful
very strong
but not for rick
[Music]
he didn't even get to attack i feel bad
for the man
i feel bad for him
all right
and you're dead
black night kingdom caled is dead
clean rot night um i know where the
death right bird is
i am not gonna kill the big dragon i
don't think that's a boss
i know where the urgery avatar is
let's go to the knights cavalry are we
close are we close to that
it's like over
it's over here we need to go this way to
kill the urgery avatar as well
don't feel bad for him it's what rick
would have wanted dark souls is supposed
to be the strongest lord soul so it may
have shared amongst the
lords pygmy
first time
yeah yeah
played plenty of souls but never figured
out what kind of powers the
pygmy got when they obtained the dark
soul i don't know if like
yeah i'm not sure
how that works
has this always been here i feel like it
hasn't
oh
nope there it is
that's what we wanted boys
oh god i'm dead
that's so i can't believe that hit me
dude
that random explosion
yeah this one has very deadly farts very
deadly farts
and i think there's a uh
a dungeon right next to here as well
behind the earth tree yeah someone said
that yeah yeah
definitely
i hate that move too
no not the stinky
it's the stinky
figure that would do it
the stinky
i like the music though
[Music]
mistake
jesus
welcome bibs
yeah if you don't run in one direction
you get hit by those every time
gotta run one way
the
stinky oh my god damn stop spamming it
are you finding a new patch i mean it
was just a bunch of bug fixes so
it's all right
i think it disappointed a lot of people
right oh good we're gonna spam it again
very nice
very nice
the stinky
oh we got to get that dragon on the
bridge as well we do it's true
and he's dead mark it off
we're getting a lot done today boom dead
all right uh
let's go kill the dragon
oh we're near that night as well we
should do that
sakura is much harder than elden ring i
agree i don't think eldon rings hard at
all um just certain parts of it are
i would say alden ring is
probably the easiest yeah
dark souls 3 might be easier than eldon
ring in some parts
they all have their own difficulties
there was a patch yesterday it just
fixed a bunch of bugs it wasn't like
that crazy
yep i'm getting the getting this guy
and then we'll go up and fight the
dragon
and then there's a cave i should have
gone to the cave right behind the earth
tree avatar
oh man
there's a lot we can do okay let's get
it
needs to be night time
yeah i would i would say it's like a
really good starter not maybe not a
starter
maybe not a starter pack
because i wouldn't want to put it in
that way
i mean
it's a good game it's it's an amazing
game i i would say like dark souls 3
is maybe the easiest one
well maybe dark souls won
they all can be easy and hard in their
own ways
i forgot to make it nighttime i'm silly
stupid
unless we've already killed this guy i
don't remember
yeah it was a nighttime yet
i think sakiro has the
i think sakura is probably the hardest
game but has the best combat
[Applause]
heroes combat is just unreal good
this is just pretty much dark souls 3's
combat
with new stuff
and you can jump
like shakiro
[Music]
best combat one weapon
yeah i didn't say it had the best
weapons it has the best combat
that's not what that means
uh-oh we're gonna throw
oh come on now
nice mark it off
yep
we are rolling right now where are you
at knights cavalry dead
let's go beat the dragon
up top
rick soldier of god
i did uh there was like a huge tick tock
that went viral on
like
having that knight's cavalry guy go into
like the uh
what was it
yeah the poison
[Music]
yeah yeah
more skill based gameplay
yeah it's like it's definitely like a
get good simulator
i don't know what the most keynote means
now that hurt
oh
that's so unfucking unfortunate it's so
hard fighting this guy on a bridge
so this is flying dragon grail
so you're gonna use a fire attack now
probably
nope
we're up
no you're gonna be in some stupid spot
okay
i'm stuck in his
leg pit
yeah why is it called flying dragon like
aren't they like
what do you mean flying they all fly
that's a good point
i'm not a big fan of the dragon fights
in this game the ones that are like this
anyway
the first one in the lake is sick
in lim grab that one's really cool but
then after that it's like oh
they're just re-skins of the same thing
kind of like the archery avatars
pretty much exactly the same
what did it get stuck
well
easy peasy mark it off
let's call this stream market off baby
uh
flying dragon gray heel perfect let's
get it let's get it
let's go back to the urgery avatar
um
and go in the cave
that's right behind it
wait
we're dead oh yeah that's the one here
yeah okay
isn't there a cave down here too
let me go here
we're making progress baby
you don't like fighting the same thing a
thousand times i i don't know
what the [ __ ]
scary
i have help on ranallo
what are you struggling with
there's definitely a cave down here
ow
no you're dead
there's a bear
calamity was awesome
cave
dragon ball cape
yeah mid-ear
mid-ear is the best dragon we're ever
going to get
actually dragon lord place of deus ex
was
probably better
probably
they're both really good
i love the dragon lord it's one of my
favorite fights in the game
[Music]
it's an unkillable bear
why is this bear so have so much help
this bear is like 50 000 health
[Music]
this not a boss okay
bro
you
oh cool i couldn't see that's great
oh good
all right
is there a boss in this cave
why is that bear so insanely strong
a imagine going there when you're level
like 70 to 100 like you should be in
caleb that bear would be impossible
that's so odd
no it's my own checklist
bro that that fight straight up sucks
balls
they're juiced
it's a rune bear i've definitely killed
a rune bearer
way faster
than that
that's ridiculous
shut up dear
don't pay any mind to the giant sword
moving and sticking out
everybody are you what's the point of
what's the point then oh you could
probably see it i'm running
i was crouched
we'll go talisman
oh it's not it's not okay
get me out oh i can't i can't leave what
does that do
raises poise
i could use that
did you rot breath him i don't have any
rot
is there more to this cave
run voice
i thought i died there a deer died
there is
is there a boss
in the bottom section okay
you go side path dropping a hole
here
hey thank you
bear avoided
i don't like killing dogs
i'm rick rolling baby rick rolling
[ __ ]
yes slicer
dude guys if you haven't already check
my community post i put out this morning
that's the thumbnail of the next video
and it's freaking awesome
you haven't seen it yet
all right how easy is this gonna be
it's gonna be hard or easy i'm getting
this one
ah one's ranged and one's not i got it
oh i can definitely see dying to this
kill one time
why would i put a guitar in the
thumbnail
huh
let me get yes
growing knife and cleaver
what
didn't step through that
and you're done
it would look more metal
okay
we do like metal
this is true all right mark it down mark
it off mark it off give me a mark
okay uh that was
we're in caled right
yeah yeah yeah yeah
future tree spirit future avatar beat
you
um
are they not on here am i blind
am i blind i can't see them
i don't see them on here
knock sword and knocks priest
no
frenzy duelist
listed under the in the into the whip
thing it's in the description is it not
on here or is it on a different one
where am i definitely caleb
definitely caleb
real watchdog falling star beast
i don't see it cemetery shake not knight
death right bird
watchdog falling star beast frenzy
duelist
mad pumpkin heads
magma worm
knock sorceress and priest
future tree spirit
i mean that's caleb
uh okay i guess it's not on here well we
did it
anyway
let me look around
wasn't it like throwing
throwing
or it was uh
barham
crumbly pharah missoula
beastoffer in missoula
it's not here okay well whatever we did
it
i don't want to [ __ ] with the list
we did it anyway
i'm trying to think of other bosses here
trying to think trying to think we
haven't gone here
i don't think
whoa oh [ __ ] okay
i don't think we've gone in this cave
or have we
man we were already right there
actually we can just ride there we're
good
oh let's go behind the urgery avatar
right above us
die stupid bear
okay you get to live for now
that's the gold scarab cave
okay
fight the last boss in lindgrave do you
mean patches which we can't fight
pretty sure that's the last one i put on
there
patches
can't kill him though it's part of a
questline
i
believe we finished
nikki tree
lies beyond stinky avatar oh no
well we gotta do it right
you gotta do it
back here
not back here
am i tripping
why do i feel like this is different
it's a different tree
i think it's this tree i'm thinking of
um
technically we've beaten all the shard
bearers yeah
we have every great room
one two three four
one two three four five six yes
yeah it's this tree yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
he'll tanith and kill patches in the
shaded castle
what are you doing in the shaded castle
patches joseph
oh
why is there two of these
what's the other one i killed them
yeah we're gonna fight all of them yes
[Music]
stinky
stinky
oh come on bro
hey thank you amir you have a great day
too man
easy all right
let's get it
there it is
don't kill patches and ruin my day
uh i glanced and didn't see the jar
knights on there are you going to fight
them the jar knights
the jar knights i don't know what that
is
okay let me check that
because that was the putrid avatar so
there that might
the other one must have just been the
urgery avatar and caitlyn
right
that we already have checked
so putrid avatar is checked okay we're
good
yeah that one was really easy for some
reason
do the jaw
jar lore you say
can you go down here yeah
crabby boys
[Music]
i killed him with my butter knife are
you still doing your prisoner play
through metal
you haven't even beat the game yet right
you haven't had time
oh i hate you i hate these imps
bruh
i hate you
there we go
remember yesterday when i said i don't
hate anybody i hate the m's
what up jar man fam
is there like an invisible anything
around here
i'm getting vibes
i thought i could beat it over spring
break foolish
foolish ambitions
put those to rest
hey what was the point of down here it's
nothing
i missed something
[Music]
what
you're dead
you're dead
pretty sure the amps were fine before
hey i didn't attack them they attacked
me
so technically it's their fault
that they're dying
ow
yeah i said i don't know what that is
terrinator
i'm not sure what that is
the jar heads
i do not remember
who or what that is
you know i think we can go up
the three red summons in front of mondo
jar oh yeah is i mean is that a boss
i could do it
anyway wanted to say hello to everyone
i'm gonna go and watch the rest of the
lore video have a great day johnny and
thanks for watching man appreciate it
enjoy the video
it's not a boss that's probably why it's
not on the list
now actually
just go down
your mom's a hoe
see ya
yeah because i went down there
slice and dice them up potential i could
do that
where's the door to this place
i think i have to actually just go down
here
is this where i went already yep already
been here
hmm
this way
i am confusion
[Music]
this takes me all the way back up is the
door actually all the way up there
that's just the front door right
yeah okay hold on i think i have to go
under the elevator again
so hard to remember how
and where things are in this game
for as much as i played it
yep
great violent
so what was down here
free spirit
probably
ah
the two of them huh
okay
pain that hurt
holy [ __ ]
howie
god
trying to time
the attacks of these guys
ridiculously hard
nope
here's one
easy peasy
scepter and sword
[Applause]
sees
archery burial watchdog minor urgery so
that that must be that right
yeah
the names on here are kind of weird
i believe we killed the putrid tree
spirit
that's in melania's area we definitely
did a hundred percent
um
okay so where is
where's a falling star beast in caled
chat where is that let's go do that next
i don't remember a falling star beast
here
at all
i'd still need to go there too
balcony
in a cave
i think it must be this one because i'm
pretty sure this one is the magma worm
okay let's go to here first
okay
thank you thank
yeah you tunnel is the magma worm
yeah it's where you get moonvale as well
excuse me
oh [ __ ]
oh that's where that is huh
oh
that was crazy i haven't been to celia
not not a single time bro
we can get there like this okay i know
where i'm going now got it
that's funny we haven't been through
celia because i did a skip
i'll probably use this too
i i just did a total skip to get through
there
i'll show you it
kind of funny when you know what you're
doing and part of gallery's quest line
is to give you the secret to celia to
like open the thing but you can just
run right past it pretty much
uh oh well that works too
i didn't mean to do that but hey here we
are
works for me chief
okay
uh not exactly where i want to be
there's a godskin fight in celia
what
where when really
that's not where i want to drop down to
oh it's this
where is there a godskin fight here what
am i tripping
we want to go over there
got it
yeah that's in the tower
is the titan jar moved to the close
where
is the titan jar is moved that is close
to where you're at
now finding the following service
i didn't understand that sentence
my dyslexia may have hit very hard there
rock grease
all right let's go through here
real death was a great rune what power
do you think it would give you the power
to distribute death
since that's what it does
in the lore
i'll leave all these guys alone
they're just working
if i see one of them centipedes though
i'm killing it
is there cringe
i break this
no ah [ __ ] i thought i was asleep
you come down here
thanks
that you regret that now don't
now
is the boss at the bottom of here at the
top
ew
a runark i should use that
actually i think i can only go down or
up
where am i right now
doesn't this send you somewhere or what
did before
it's like the back okay
okay
you're done
you're done
i'm kind of lost right now
i'm assuming it's back there
so looks like i need to do some hardcore
parkour
i didn't scream
you did
okay
go
i want meat
i want you
are you saying you're hungry just in a
really odd way
[Music]
another one
what up stan how are you
how could you stream during my lunch
time isn't that what you guys want to
watch a stream while you're like eating
or something i don't know
whenever i'm watching streams or
watching youtube i am always just like
eating
[Music]
something ooh
what are they praising a hole in the
wall
hey nice faithful canvas talisman don't
feel like we have that already
cats horny as always
as always
i don't have enough hands
all right that's a falling star beast if
i've ever seen one
really weak
doesn't even have eyes
this one must be a baby
this is just the bowl from sakiro don't
get it twisted
dead
favorite bros boss lore wise radon
my answer will always be redone
all right mark it off
mark it off
good [ __ ] blind star beast dead
frenzy duelist who's that where's that
actually shut up let me go kill the
magma worm
i'm sorry i just told you
i asked you a question i'm like shut
up my bad my bad my bad okay
i know where i want to go that's why i
said that sorry all right
nicole
the frenzied one the boss in the gale
cave i mean we're about to go in gale
cave um i think this is a magmor is it
frenzied i haven't i haven't
noticed that
i just hate the magma worm so much that
i barely pay attention to the fight
i'm not gonna kill all these guys
bro i thought i was gonna roll but i
didn't roll bruh didn't no i didn't roll
dude
okay i know you're talking about now
joseph i got you man you don't have to
keep telling me
goal in k in jail are two different
caves oh
now we know
the [ __ ] do you guys remember these cave
names
i play this game as my job and i don't
remember
it might be because i'm dumb as well
[Music]
oh you're googling it okay
i just thought you guys were that smart
you just knew
see i play this game as a job how do you
have more hours than me
you have 150 more hours than me and i
play this game for a living
that's crazy
hey maybe you play this game for a
living i have no idea
okay magma worm
worst fight in the game but you get
moonville
[Music]
spot seems safe
you get up in that bung
hole dead
what should i name my new hamster
boy or girl
okay
let's get it this build is really strong
that was
the [ __ ] magma worm
dead
uh
knox swordstress and knox priest where
is this chat that's that's gonna be our
next one knox knox swordstress in knox
priest
how do you mean you play this game for a
living
i do i stream and make videos for this
game
for a living that's what i mean i don't
think there's any other way
that's that's in celia
really
did i even get anything
any of the thingies
i'll just go here
i have 600 hours and i'm level 323 i
just be ratting on the other beast i
swore so much without being this game
how do you have that many hours like
have there been that many hours since
the game came out i played this game
every day for hours on end
i guess you guys do too
that's crazy
can be found very northwest of celia
town of sorcery
very northwest side of celia
okay
whoa that school looks scary up there
that looks scary bro
let me get
this i don't believe you guys have that
much play time really i mean do you guys
just like have your monitor or your like
your game on while you're eating or
something like you're not actually
playing are you really playing that much
that seems like a lot i'm not trying to
like dog you for playing that much but
like holy [ __ ]
okay very north west side
northwest would be here
is it inside of here
it's too hot to go outside i
i bet
i like it
i have 15 000 hours
i don't think that many hours have
happened yet
since the game came out
big archway at the top
[Music]
a seal was broken
yeah i have like 350 hours
i have to break all the seals
i don't even think i know where all the
seals are
up there
i think i have to jump on from the
mountain
whoa
i have 200 hours with your mom
do not dog christy he's a saint
painter over there
i don't know why i overthought this okay
that one didn't open it but i lit that
one i just wanted to see
ah
dude
pouring platforming 10 out of 10.
hey i'm just doing all the seals because
you guys told me to
this one just opens the main door i
think
oh i was wrong
a lot of time taking screenshots
absolutely
i did the same
have been doing the same
where's uh
is there only one more seal okay so we
got that one
oh and then it's the big one over there
right
so i have to get to the top of the hill
let me get this too
oh see i don't touch pvp at all
i don't touch pvp
i don't know what it is about pvp with
this game but it seems not
nice
not friendly
i do want to try the seamless co-op mod
i really do
um
my friends are on a minecraft binge
right now
and cole's not a giant fan of elden ring
that's fine
you are missing nothing i mean that's
what i thought it's a big part of the
game though and i think it's important
doesn't look like there's a bell on that
at all
um
foreign
all right
is there a bit
there's got to be an easier way to get
up there am i just overthinking it i
probably am
statue of america
it's not that tower
oh
so i over thought that one huh oh it's
that one right there i didn't even see
that
what
i'm so silly
all right guys
i'm so silly
hahaha missed that
platforming
okay
such a silly uber use
okay why did i see it and now i don't
i'm just like so weird
oh i missed it i'm so silly let me go
back
yeah i must be so annoying right now i'm
sorry
dude just go to that bridge
just do this branch
i'm purposely triggering you
okay
pour it
no please oh god
i i didn't mean to do that one
it's the only way i know how to get up
here too
listen blame torrent it's his fault
okay i'm getting off of torrent now and
i'm on the
i'm on the ladder
i want to talk about it okay we got it
where's the boss
light it up rick
it's true i love torrent
you said far northwest corner right
get up wizard
i'ma see what this is
big archway
north
so here ah okay
what we got in here
oh i see a couple of foreheads
okay
you're dead
next time
can i just kill you please
we'll attack
i'm gonna die
and it's gonna be funny
there it is
little do you know that i'm into whips
cool sword
what's in here
oh a glintstone staff
all right knock it off knock it off
get off okay
we're getting caleb done mad pumpkin
heads where are they
i think i know
i think i know where they are
yeah we're kind of owning i mean just so
you guys know we've beaten melania at
this point
like we're kind of killing it
like if we're beating melania we're
beating everybody
it's the most powerful staff for a
sorcerer
that's cool all right ruins right yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm getting weirdly hyper so you know
it's happening it's happening randomly
my hyperness is getting
for intrigued and horny wow
if i can do both i'm doing something
right
die
please leave me be
alright where
you're dead idiot
aren't the mad pumpkin heads where those
uh
little cart dudes are
with the puppet heads
there ain't nothing in there
these aren't the right ruins they're
here
oh my god how could you go to the wrong
ruin
imagine not knowing where it is
dude just for stan i'm gonna have to go
and like beat gun deer for the memes
yeah flamethrower dudes
they're over here
this is where we want to be
yeah yeah
okay
and ye
fire
all right two pumpkin heads
double mad pumpkin head
[Music]
lol
imagine being a pumpkin head
a big old stupid doodoo head
made fun of his pumpkin
all right
mark it off
progress
frenzy duelist where's that
where's frenzy duelist
i'm on a roll baby
it's in the description
it's the first thing in the description
you forehead
how can they see they can't
goal cave where's that
that's that that's where we're getting a
little all right you know we have this
well okay
i don't have that unlocked so i don't
know where it is
haven't been
northwest of fort gill
girl
that's ferrith
or is there another fort here
[Music]
[Music]
you're saying that because of subnautica
stan shut up
oh bro if we could have done a
subnautica stream on youtube dude oh my
god
it's southwest
so i'm in the right area huh
i'm in the right area
i'm just kind of lost in the sauce right
now
you guys like subnautica
oh there it is oh wait that's red man
that's a big boy
subnautica was so much fun to play on
stream
it's too bad we did it in front of like
five people on twitch
where where where
i am confused now
it's over there
oh
wait
it's that
then replay it on stream
i admit man i say this every stream but
it does it does scare me
very much
to play a different game
on youtube
scares me to make a new
to make content on any other game very
scary
because
youtube loves consistency man they
really do
you dude
yeah i know i could have gone
you know do a closer thing i i just i
was getting lost
y'all let me do my thing here i
apologize for being a stupid poo poo doo
doo head
make a different channel then no that's
really not how that works at all
guys i'm here
okay
yeah i am curious of how the quarry
would do on
on stream
or not on stream but
making content for the quarry like if i
made a plate like a
a series of me playing the quarry i i
wonder how well that would do because
that game looks really fun
got it
i play the quarry with you
is it multiplayer
okay i almost dodged that in a really
cool way guys what am i looking for here
what am i doing here
is this where you told me to go
this is getting a bit out of game
imagine being late rammy i'm just
kidding well
i think four games have a vote
it's down in the swamp
oh
see i was gonna go in there
voice dominated multiplayer i thought it
was a single player horror game
down there huh
in the swamp right
it's heavy on choices
well yeah
help you make decisions in game the
thing is are they quick decisions or are
they slow like are there like we could
take our time
and have like chat pick the answer and
stuff
all right i'm going down here
now is it in a cave
yeah they're quick so we wouldn't have
time
this looks like a cave
hey um
[Music]
well that seemed unfair and stupid but
that's okay
i don't care
cat would not be able to pick they give
you like five to seven seconds to choose
so yeah definitely not
i you know i
how how do you guys think a let's play
would do though like if i recorded it on
my own time
and played it
edited it i have no idea
because i just want to play games
and make content for them
[Music]
an elden ring is [ __ ] awesome i don't
i don't plan on stopping with elden ring
at any point but i don't want to get
inconsistent at all
you know
where people be like i thought you were
the lore guy where i really don't think
i am
oh
creepy down here
yeah i might test the waters
watching a streamer at night she does
pulls not all are quick so not all of
them are quick okay
oh here we
go
minecraft let's play yeah not like that
you know
i display it see how it does
okay
on youtube you present yourself as
someone who does lore theories
well yeah
obviously
holy [ __ ] it's creepy down here
i don't think i'm the lore guy though i
think i'm an outlier where it's like um
i think i'm easier to watch
than other lore youtubers
not anyone in specifically but
like
i'm not
i'm more simple i guess
at least that's how i see myself could
be wrong that's why i'm asking
gotcha
how else would you make elder ring
content if you don't let me at least
mention lore it's such a lore-heavy game
well i there's plenty of content like i
don't know faze jeb just played the game
but i guess he's faze jeff
none of the other streamers ask if we're
feeling randy though
exactly
this is where i'm different
i don't know
yeah i really like phase job
i know he's playing the quarry
so i think that could be fun
i'm not worried about copyright it's
fine
listen i i here's here's why i'm scared
okay i have
tried to be a content creator for such a
long time and it's finally starting to
work out so i don't want to [ __ ] it up
that's all
and in the past every time i try to
change up the content that i make it
[ __ ] it up
so that's why it's scary
yeah i think we i i would be comfortable
doing anything on stream
what i'm not comfortable with is making
videos in a different way
yet
i should have uh
prefaced that as well my bad
yep rl flashbacks
exactly
uh
[Music]
i don't know what that opened but we
gonna find out
you
you
i'm learning about more dlc so the
content train won't be stopping for a
while yeah we just don't know when that
is
like i'm not worried about
yeah i'm not worried about that
all i'm saying is i would like to play
other games as well
now the way to the boss is open well now
all these guys are waddling around
make a rick theme song oh it's in the
works
it's in the works
so all the doors opened it looks like
i'm confused
how's mom and joy they are excellent
thank you for asking
this cave is confusing i don't know
where i am
this seems promising
never mind
rather torrent or leonard warren
leonard is only for radon
this is gale cave
how do you pronounce it jioli
goalie
you guys are creepy why are they all
just on fire
what's going on here
hello
rainbow stone little golden rooney
action
[Music]
oh this looks fake as hell
wrong
no that's a different one
we were in a jail cave earlier this is a
different one
[Music]
oh god hello
[Music]
oh there's a piece of wood back here
huh
these wood planks
ah thank you
we
hello
oh
dude that was cool he tore off like a
coat
you're bad at the game
dead
mark it off
so quick
we're almost done with caleb cemetery
shade clean rot night
death right bird i know where the bird
is let's go do that
write it off
right that [ __ ] off
um it's like over here
so
yeah we murdered that guy wasn't even
remotely remotely close
that was kind of cool he tore off a coat
before he turned around
yeah what were we talking about
yeah i'm i'm willing to stream whatever
i think that would be fine but making
just
videos
of different content is scary
i'm gonna focus on death right here
because i don't like fighting these
birds
these birds are tu
ha ha ha
but yes i think we could stream the
quarry
whoops nighttime
it's mogan time
there it be
it's the [ __ ] bird bro
stop trying to pack me dogs
nice try
i shouldn't have talked
what is that range
bruh
these fights suck
yes
awful
terrible
very cool
though but those birds dude just spam
[ __ ]
all right let's get on this let's get on
this death raper dead
we've got clean rot knight cemetery
shade where'd you say cemetery shade was
again
yeah that weapon that you get from him
is really good i just closed that
nice jake good [ __ ] jake let's try that
again dude
accidentally closed instead of minimized
but we got opera gx
this saves everything
southwest
shut up oh it actually is
southwest near the very bottom
uh-oh uh-oh
oh my controller okay southwest near the
very bottom
at the cemetery duh
[Music]
drew so not this bottom huh
where is it
i've never looked under the bridge
that's east whoops
whoops
a whoops
[Music]
golden scarab cave on the cliff
east of dragon communion
east
demon souls for free let's oh dude
let's go
[Music]
down here i'm assuming
taking a risk
paid off
that looks like a cave
that was me
no
not one of those no
only in my nightmares
this falls from the sky
i've come to kill you
gideon's wondering what's taking you so
long yeah we killed malakat and he's
like what the [ __ ] is he doing
what's he doing out there
we're making progress gideon
stupid forehead
that's right
he's a stupid forehead
flower power
okay
that's there
we're just gonna get infected that's
fine no big dealio
oh it's a revenant
where do we go
big wall okay
this one
this one
oh god
fake wall center of the rod
it is so hard to give directions through
chad isn't it
bro the amount of people that are like
yo dude shackle
or like everything in this game
is it in here
you said it was in the rot oh
[ __ ]
of a [ __ ]
open up
i'm gonna end this fight as soon as
possible
yes revenants are the worst enemies in
the game
[ __ ] you
mark it off boys
mark it off
all right green light cream
clean rot night where is it
last one in caled
one more in caled
the rot never bothered him anyway
one more in caleb
[Music]
close to the rake of lake of rot and
celia
cliff cave
the rot never bothered him anyway
underground cave
the one that's like in here
on a cliff near the merchant
this is not new game plus no
we're just level 135 now
i don't know where to go
i have to drop down to it
but it's in here
you're breathtaking
you guys said drop down
guys don't spam it please
finn say up one more time i will ban you
i swear
stop you're not helping
up doesn't mean [ __ ]
[Music]
is it in that elevator
that this takes you somewhere else right
why would i parkour when i can just be
there like over there
you want me to jump from that cliff to
there
when i could just
be there
i'm definitely not making lore videos on
bloodborne that's already been done
so many times
i subzero
is it down in the elevator though
oh i see
is that a cave
oh i see
got it
got it
holy [ __ ] you guys are terrible you
can't just say up
come on dude
oh no
are you blind oh it's broken
oh
cool
okay hopefully this isn't too crazy
whoa
there is creepy dude
they're all broken [ __ ] horror game
to have those guys around
you know i really could just like pull
up the wiki and look up everything and
it'll give me an exact location of
everything but i think it's more fun to
just have a confusing chat room what do
you guys think
oh i'm pulling okay okay dude
all right
that was the wrong one sick
all right we're just looking like a
[ __ ] out here right now
[Music]
okay the intros for them are cool
but they're really easy
i shouldn't have talked
the intro's really cool though
caleb oh
there's two
oh oh
there's two
holy [ __ ]
golden schedule
skip
caleb done
do we have to kill patches for you guys
to be like yeah you can mark it off
do we have to murder patches
to mark off uh limb grave
man we've already been live three hours
might have to finish this another day
because there's no way we're finishing
today no shot
we finished caleb though that's pretty
good bro
that's pretty good
skin soldier we could go do that
finley's a she
the one who carried melania
i'm not going to the great jar it's not
a boss so i'm not doing it
not doing it
caleb complete
um
landale real capital i do know where
that bell bearer is or the bell hunter
hopefully it's not as hard as the other
one because jesus christ
because jesus christ
you know what chat
i'll murder patches if i want to
or i am rick
and i can do whatever i desire
i
um my game froze
my game is frozen
this is bad okay all right that was a
really long freeze but here we are we're
fine
you can tell me no
but i am rick
and i will murder who i wish
aren't these the crazy flying ones
anymore
oh my god
no we're talking about a [ __ ] uh
oh i could probably stress huh
maybe a half the past time even though
it's already nighttime
you kill him we will unsubscribe
bet
that's not where we do this for the bell
bearer
is someone there
a customer well
how long has it been
a while
okay
there we go
you have to talk to the merchant it's
kind of interesting
hello
where is it
oh
i can get a big hit there maybe a stag
there's our stag
see that one was way easier than the
caitlyn one
way easier
all right mark it
mark
mark
dead
divine bridge gollum
uh
gideon's on here
godfrey first eldon lord we just need to
kill the golem
isn't there only one way to get up there
which is like to go into some weird uh
tower
like
over here
right
over here
yeah i feel like the cabled one is
broken
yeah chest teleport am i looking in the
right direction isn't it here
i think
[Music]
yup it is here
crazy how that takes you to like
the capitol
one sec
you okay
can upload notice you didn't kill the
elden beast yet what's up with that
we're killing everyone else first stan
duh
we are just making so much insanely
good progress
we could kill i think we kill um gideon
and godfrey to end leondell and then
tomorrow we go for the rest
easy
ensnared in a transporter trap
from there you get melania's great rune
yes we can do that too
and patches i don't even know where
patches is
i didn't know this was a boss
it's not
why is this considered a boss because it
has to be this one that it's talking
about right
oh i thought i knocked you over
is there a different golem
that isn't this one that would be a boss
in lay and l
oh god please no
oh god please no
that was close
here we go
i just thought it was referring to this
one as a boss
the list
let's get melania's great room though we
could actually use that
i don't think there's any golem bosses
either well there's the one but we
definitely killed it
rick
rick
i'm pickle rick
it's considered a boss okay
give it a boss thing then boss meter
health meter
i'm gonna check it off though because
that has to be the divine bridge golem
it has to be
oh esker priests of blood where's that
that's our next one
and then we'll kill gideon and godfrey
and then we'll come back tomorrow
esker priest of blood
oh he's in the shaded castle okay
can we use melania's great room
leon dell catacombs
i know where that is got it thank you
it's not the chance
that is
so we went
prescription we need to go to this right
yep
yup
okay go back up though
hey
hi chat
wrong then what's in here
we were talking about that earlier
sub-zero
we're thinking the quarry
is there a boss in here
looks like it
i may not stream tomorrow
not sure
i want to work on the video tomorrow
well i should stream tomorrow because i
really want to get this done this uh
i have to wait anyway to release the new
video so oh
what the [ __ ]
not the blood guy
well it looks like i need to kill him
then where am i now
oh is this the weird one
yes it is
remember there's like several
yeah
look how far back this guy went
you
hit it
that still hurts huh
all right lit
there we go didn't get ensnared that
time
that's a glitch that it's doing that
i have to go down here first
and get this
laying dell catacombs
i mean i'm in laying down
got a couple of potholes
oh that's cool
um
there's a ladder here
yeah this is really confusing if i
remember right i have been here before
though
yeah probably i just haven't come across
them as we've been doing this
if we beat melania we're looking good
okay there we go
so the doors open
okay
wait
so i need to hit this now
to go up
subterranean ground side of grace down
to the pipe area then drop all the way
down run past the lobsters and into the
doorway
for the blood guy
see now it's in here
i think we're back
hey don't worry about it i'm confused
too
a big pot boy
why did they make these pots
so like insane when they die
this giant explosions
i don't know how to get out of here now
yup gotta lay down the pipe you know
what i'm saying
you know you know what i'm saying chat
you gotta lay down the pot
lay down the pipe
[Music]
just wonder what boss this is
cause i checked it off like i already
did it oh this sends you down here [ __ ]
yeah that's what i should have done
andrew
but i'm a little stupid
sometimes i'm okay though
you know i i i i can be uh i can be i
can be cool
what's up here now
this should
i am confused
dude i have a lantern and i use it all
the time
there you go sorry and turn it on
sorry
this is what we wanted
and
gladiator guy with pots
hey what's his name
brave warden duelist
what do you guys do after he's dead
explode
nice
is that even on here grave warden
duelist
uh
[Music]
nope
well we did it
i don't see it anywhere can i search it
rave
it's over here in limb grave but we did
it all right
done
so you guys said
sacred subterranean hunting grounds
cathedral of the forsaken forsaken
depths
soul jars of fortune
okay where do you want me to go
well must be
anyway we did it
underground roadside oh
like here okay
okay
[Music]
and what we looking for
this one is moog
okay you're talking about the other one
i'm not gonna get confused
just looking up where i go from here
forward and down yeah you said the
lobsters and stuff yeah okay
[ __ ] ass
somewhere down there right
we've already killed moog so we don't
need the shackle
[Music]
see you
[ __ ]
[ __ ] imps bro
okay that just looks like death
nice one idiot
is it that doorway over there
yeah yeah we know the rainbow stone
thing
let me take the hit
i don't know about you guys but i do not
[ __ ] with the lobsters
i guess sneaking does not work on the
lobsters
[ __ ] it i don't care what that is
[ __ ]
there's other stuff over there
but i am not messing around with the
lobsters
they [ __ ] with me
ah just come back to life huh
race right by the entry
what
is
[ __ ] where
thanks
so do we want to go down
after we beat this guy we will go fight
gideon yes
ah that's where the door is
oh we go this way though
i hear things in the water
[Music]
you guys are strong
why did i grab it like that the [ __ ]
never grabbed anything like that
i'm on controller
yo what up
are those guys already dead
[Music]
okay
no stagger there
there it is
using shackle drops pillars oh my god
you guys talk about the shackle
so much
we can just walk past it we're good okay
before i go down there i want to see
what's over here
dun dun dun dun dun dun
would like to go up please
hello
this dungeon's a mental trip
crucible scale talisman what's that
reduce it wait
reduces damage taken from critical hits
there
that's that i
that's
okay does everything explode
i don't know
they're exploding
i just gotta remember that this is a
video game sometimes you know what i'm
saying it is a video game we don't gotta
overthink everything
oh is this the beginning
yes they are supposed to be children of
nobility
oh i i did open the door when did i open
the door i don't remember doing this
hello
are you a boss
oh
what is this what's happening
they can hurt each other
holy [ __ ]
oh he's going off bro stop please for a
second
very nice
yeah
was that supposed to be the boss
what just happened
it's a boss room
what happened
the door is open
it's a maze
oh whoa okay
it should debate
cool
neato burrito bro
cuz i was like i don't remember opening
the door
did we open the door
wait whoa whoa whoa yeah
oh i'm tripping out right now bro
bruh
what
he's here looking at his dead friend or
maybe a dead version of himself
whoa
hey jump down again
the door's not there
whoa
okay
whoa
whoa this is cool
i've never been in this dungeon
whoa
this is really cool i like this whoa
huh
hey two of them should i go back that
way
oh no
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
it's so much damage come on bro
okay so i see it dead over there
[Music]
the guy i killed is dead
so jump go this way
are you guys tripping out too like this
is wicked bro
oh [ __ ]
wait wait i want to check this
[Music]
wait
that's what we want huh
no i'm not on top
i like being on top
see we did that
oh
what
yo this is trippiest balls
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
it's the lever boys
i don't know where we are but
i hear it over here
hey
let's go
holy [ __ ] that is the coolest dungeon
for sure
[Music]
that's the coolest dungeon i've been in
100
what is this
look at you
little knocked off mode huh
that's just absolutely absurd okay
oh you could kill me in a second oh wow
look at that hoodie
it's a smurf
lord of bloods exultation
yeah what's that
this is so cool
blood loss is
infinity blood loss in vicinity
increases attack power
interesting
he's a part of our
dynasty
little moog wannabe all right let's do
it let's kill gideon and
godfrey then i think we'll be done for
today
cause that'll finish off landel
oh [ __ ] we gotta talk to corwin over
here too
we gotta finish corwin
isn't he over this way
pretty sure
or cory not for win
upon my name as soldier of god
rick there he is
our boy's gonna be obsetting spaghetti
oh
it's you
i finally come to understand
it's all a lie bro more than a
enchanted by a vain and ruinous delusion
he rejected the perfection of the golden
order
seeking to supplant our glorious faith
with his own
[Laughter]
could there be
a more pitiable comedy
look at it
the culmination of perfection
burning
before our very eyes
yeah i did that
i did that
sorry oh
it's you i finally come to the master
was nothing more than enchanted seeking
to molly says look at it the culmination
of
[Laughter]
all right guys
do i murder him
let me know
yes or no
damn
[Music]
no metal
wow
put him out of his misery
[Music]
i need to reload the area
i'm pretty sure he dies right
let me go back and check
i'll run back
gold mask is dead already
he's over by the
colosseum i believe
still over here though i'm gonna murder
him
there he is he's gone
i should have murdered him huh
should have killed him
i think to get to god the gold mask i
need to kill gideon anyway
let's go get him
yes we killed melania
rick is so happy
pretty sure gold mask is
any over there
not yet
alright guys
it's him
[Music]
yeah i think nevermind
rp walk
ah
i knew you'd come
to stand before the elden reign
to become elden lord
what a sad state of affairs
i commend your spirit but alas
none shall take the throne god has high
hopes for us that we continue to
struggle
onto eternity
oh my god
he's got millennium stuff
that was sick
[Music]
this might actually be really tough
[Music]
because he has everything
he's doing hella damaged
he's got every attack from everybody
we've fought against
i think i just need to go at him
yeah i know guys
he's been stalking us he's using
everything that we've had
everything we've bought against
mimik's out
[Applause]
that infected me fast
yeah i'm already infected
oh i need to heal like right
i didn't think those would hit me
[Music]
cannot become a lord
not even you
damn
a man
cannot
kill
a god
then i guess i'm a god aren't i
then i guess i'm a god
the mimic's name is rick it is a mimic
so it means it's me
so yes
his name is rick
now
on to the first elden lord
i believe i can go back and get uh
actually let's do that now
why does he believe a man can't kill a
god
um
because that's what he's been told
what he that's just what he thinks
he's been manipulated heavy i think by
queen america
is gold mass this way
i forget
statue's gone
what's over here
don't know the logic why you would
betray us you can go watch my videos on
it
smithing stone six
little bubba booze
oh he's right here
there he is
arms still straight out
mending roon of perfect order
so we'll beat godfrey
and then i will have the chat tomorrow
fuse
what ending we want to do
because if we want if we don't want
flame of frenzy then we have to go get
rid of it
you know what actually i'm gonna have
you guys choose at the end of the stream
so after we beat godfrey i'm gonna let
you guys choose and then that's the
ending we'll go for
must have really strong shoulders yeah
even in death his arms are still
sticking straight out
i don't know should i have you guys
choose tomorrow or have you choose now
also
all right melania's great rune attacks
recover hp after damage is taken i mean
[ __ ] yeah
the lowsome
dung eta
let the flame die
or whatever
yesterday
great answer great answer
let's get it
it's after this anyway i didn't pop a
runark either
yeah we want rick to sit on the throne
right
it's been
a long while
morgot
this fight's so good
it's so good
long
and hard is thou fight
tarnished warrior long and hearts burned
by the grace of gold
be assured the elden ring
resteth close at hand
alas
i am returned
to be granted audience once more
[Music]
upon my name as godfrey
the first elden lord
nice
badass
panic roll
all bad
bad start
[Music]
[Music]
dang it
can't reach me
he's so tall
so
[Music]
dude
i thought i could roll right after the
head
i'm pretty sure we're as big as his
thigh
he's so
just massive
got to get the get the rolls down
why is he steaming because he's mad that
i'm hitting him
giga godfrey
thick
oh wait
let's go rick
other
rick
let's get it
that's unfortunate did that hit me
[Music]
wow
[Music]
nice
it's
mad
that will be all why don't you buff up
you sound like a bleed man it's me good
service
suraj
f's in the chat for sirach epps in the
chat for suraj
do you guys get like long weird stutters
when they change off
the scene sometimes in cutscenes
this is the worst line in the game right
here by the way the worst line
now i fight just horror lou
warrior
i don't know why but i find it when he
says warrior to be really cringy
[Music]
wow mr delay
oh
good luck rick
yeah yeah
rick
ain't going well man
[Music]
oh rick
[Music]
sorry man
oh you like that jump over the leg sweep
that was nice
good job rick
there it is boys
there it is
now
little jump over the leg sweep that was
nice bro
all right i'm gonna ask this again
should we do
the vote for the ending
today or tomorrow because we can finish
we can finish
tomorrow i didn't get a good consensus
of what you guys wanted
yesterday
so i should do a poll before we do a
poll
right now
i'll let the mod speak
actually hold on
i'll make a poll
you know i think it would be better if
we did it tomorrow
i'll still
ask i think it would be better if we did
it tomorrow after we because we're going
to go and do all the mini bosses and
then we'll come back here
and we'll start a poll right here again
but i'll still ask you
we're doing a poll for a poll i i may uh
you know
i may over
what is it
i may veto this poll because i am
amazing
i am the streamer
does thy strength not be fit a crown
apparently it do you very well do
yeah we still got to do all the mini
bosses i i think it makes sense for
tomorrow i know you guys are saying
today obviously but
let's go tomorrow i think it makes a lot
more sense
i think it'd make a lot more sense
yeah veto's a thing uh anyway
we're gonna come back tomorrow
we're gonna go and do all the rest of
the mini bosses so we just beat gideon
and godfrey so lay in dell's done we
still got to go to some parts of mount
glamiere we got to go to the river
um
got some lake of rot to do we got to go
to the mountain tops and beat everything
we got to go all this plateau and beat a
lot of guys
uh beat a lot of bosses not guys um
learning of the lakes and we can get all
that done in a few hours tomorrow and
then we just go down to the end radagon
eldon beast we pick our ending then we
can kill patches as well
so
yeah
we'll do that tomorrow tomorrow will be
the last day
of our completionist run i will start at
some point tomorrow
and
we will just run until we beat the game
so either long stream tomorrow or
whenever we get it done so i'll be on in
the morning tomorrow more likely than
not
um but we'll get it done
we're gonna finish it in 12 days it
looks like
so
i appreciate all of the support you guys
have been awesome
never had this much fun streaming before
even when i was on twitch so
thank you you guys are great
uh
i'll be back then
so
one thing i'm trying to grow is my
twitter
um
i don't understand twitter at all it's
like the only platform that i don't get
how to grow on
naturally so
links in the description for everything
guys go follow me on twitter join our
discord our discord's actually really
cool there's just like
uh lots of channels you can do all kinds
of stuff in there like lore theories and
eldon bling and
uh just a normal chat room and stuff so
everything's in the description join the
discord follow me on twitter subscribe
appreciate all the subs we are getting
close to
65k which is really cool so thank you
um but tomorrow we are going to finish
our completionist run we're gonna we're
gonna do it we're gonna get a hundred
percent
and i'm excited for it so hopefully you
are too
then i'll be back sometime tomorrow
morning cst some point uh you know
around the same time today a little
earlier actually and we will start and
we will not stop streaming
until it is time until we finish
so anyway
thank you all very very much uh oh also
i'm gonna i'm gonna plug the patreon if
you guys want early access to all new
youtube videos like a day in advance
almost uh depending on when i put it out
um you can join our patreon
have other discussions in there as well
you get a little little hint to the next
video
but you get you get videos in advance
with no ads you get them early with no
ads so
again
everything is in the description go
check it out
and do what you want to do other other
than that i just appreciate you being
here so
have a great rest of your day and i will
see you all tomorrow and we'll finish
this thing off man i'm excited so
bye guys